put on your lip balm we got zombie
tigers zombie elvis and zombie boobs
sorry i can't show that well it's been
17 years since zack snyder brought us
his reimagined version of george a
romero's dawn of the dead
which is kind of fitting since army of
the dead ends on a sunset this time
however netflix has shelled out big
bucks apparently
90 million to make this movie which had
been in development hell since 2004.
in this video we'll be taking a deep
dive into army of the dead its ending
and some of the details you may have
missed like did you know zack snyder cut
a scene with a male stripper with a huge
penis with a bite taken out of it i want
to see that but before we begin
make sure to like and subscribe
seriously 92 percent of you aren't
subscribed i'll pump those numbers up
those are rookie numbers
so here we go army of the dead begins
with a reference to the book of
revelations and the four horsemen of the
apocalypse fitting since the horsemen
usher in the end of the world and when
you look at that there are exactly four
trucks here these guys are coming from
area 51 with a payload containing zeus
an alpha zombie who moves like my
girlfriend when she hasn't eaten just
kidding i don't have a girlfriend we
don't know much about zeus whether he's
some government experiment gone wrong an
actual alien entity or something else
entirely
but we'll get more into that in a bit i
want you to take a moment and look at
what appears to be two spacecraft going
supersonic or
even light speed i missed this on my
first watcher but it hints at alien tech
or at least
super advanced tech being used zeus ends
up completely destroying the caravan and
we never really find out where this
caravan was headed
and sets his eyes on las vegas where we
get an absolutely awesome intro credit
sequence showing the city's downfall
culminating in it being surrounded by
shipping containers to keep the zombies
contained
get it containers contained whatever
zeus will fittingly set up his kingdom
at a fictitious casino called the
olympus where a stone statue of the
greek god himself overlooks the hotel's
tower
or mount olympus unlike other zombies
commonly referred to as shamblers
zeus is an alpha and only he can create
other alphas
these alpha zombies can communicate take
orders and are faster stronger and
smarter than their shambler counterparts
but the first 50 minutes are merely a
setup to what the movie is really about
bly tanaka a wealthy businessman and
owner of the bly hotel and casino which
looks like it's ripping off the wind
once drax the destroyer to break into
his casino and retrieve the budget to
this movie before all of vegas is set to
be nuked in four days
on july 4th no less what could be more
american i thought this was america and
tanaka why didn't you just give him the
code for the vault
instead scott here is given a blueprint
with the title goddard damaron named
after the 5
hour opera by richard wagner try holding
your p for that it's also a fitting name
since god odamarang is the german name
for ragnarok or the end times in norse
mythology they're gonna need a safe
cracker by the name of dieter to open it
up i should also mention that mathias
schwaghoffer the actor who plays dieter
will be starring
in and directing the army of the dead
prequel army of thieves
which has already finished filming the
last we see of dieter in army of the
dead he's closing the vault with
zeus behind him so it looks like the
prequels are the only way we'll see his
character
back in action scott here works at a
burger joint so that 50 mil
even split between the team will go a
long way you see scott used to be in the
military alongside maria cruz and
marianne peters they all wear these loss
of vengeance badges which may refer
to the nickname of their unit the medal
we see him pick up early on in the film
is the legion of merit which is a
military award given to those who have
shown exceptional conduct in the
performance of outstanding services and
achievements but there's one thing that
scott does best
and that's run away he leaves the
military to work at a fast food
restaurant he leaves his daughter when
she needs a most after killing his
zombie wife in front of her
and he left maria who cared deeply about
him this is his character arc a man who
constantly runs away to avoid the
emotional pain of dealing with these
issues
is forced to face them while undergoing
a zombie invasion
scott will later end up doing the
opposite of runaway and ventures off to
find his daughter even though it could
mean his death this is why i personally
like army of the dead over snyder's dawn
of the dead which doesn't have any
characters with arcs at all
marianne peters played by comedian tig
notar was filmed entirely solo in front
of a green screen replacing crystalia
who's alleged to have pursued and
harassed underage women
so it's kind of a fun fu to chris to
have his character replaced by a lesbian
comedian feminist
i also think it's funny that as the crew
gets bigger and bigger the amount they
split amongst each other gets smaller
and smaller
50 million dollars two million dollars
what would you say about making 500
grand
how would you like to make 250 grand
yeah i'll make 20 [ __ ] grand here's
another fun easter egg the two political
commentators debating about whether or
not vegas should be nuked
are two disgraced real-life political
commentators donna brazile
and sean spicer a 2016 wikileaks dump
revealed brazil sent
emails to the clinton campaign with
advanced town hall questions
and sean spicer well
we're then introduced to the mccarran
quarantine zone named after senator pat
mccarron of nevada who served from 1933
to 1954. we don't know much about the
people in these zones just that they're
not free to do as they please and it's a
clear take on the southern border camps
the person who eventually agrees to
smuggle this character gita into vegas
is referred to as a coyote the name
given to those who guide others over the
border for a fee
the team is rounded out by vanderhoe and
mikey guzman and who is like some sort
of youtuber and i'm like you want to
keep a low profile and you're inviting a
youtuber this is where
this is a worse idea than logan paul
going into a japanese forest
there's also this girl named chambers
who's a total badass and also went to
the same high school as me she also
happens to play in amazon in another
small movie i had to look up
let me see here what's it called justice
league so tanaka goes over the plan with
them and was kind enough to build a
model and of course the two towers they
need to infiltrate are called sodom and
gomorrah
two cities mentioned in the bible for
their propensity to sin
i mean it makes sense you'd find this in
sin city we also meet this gem of a man
martin tanaka's head of security we'll
later find out that tanaka
never really cared about the 200 million
left in his vault the real prize is
blood from one of the alphas something
martin says
is worth 10 times that amount tanaka
doesn't give a [ __ ] about the money
what's in this bag it's worth 10 times
what's in that vault
when scott calls tanaka to tell him he's
down to do the job we see a bunch of
military guys in the background so it
looks like tanaka is in cahoots with the
us government of course the government
would want their hands on this
super-powered blood
as martin says this is the power to make
moral
power to control your own zombie army
that's the ultimate wmd
i do think it's worth exploring the idea
that zeus is extraterrestrial or whoever
or whatever infected zeus is
if the government made him then why
would they need the alpha blood they
could just make another or they'd likely
have vials of it stored to work from
this suggests the government hasn't
unlocked the power of the alpha blood
which may or may not be
of this world i think zeus himself was
indeed at one time
human when he emerges from his crate
he's wearing dog tags with a buzz cut
suggesting he was once a soldier maybe
he was a pilot that got infected with
something from outer space
after all area 51 is a united states air
force base
i also love the attention to detail with
the buzz cut here as
later on in the film when several months
have passed we'll see his hair has grown
which also suggests that alphas aren't
technically dead
they can grow hair and babies and maybe
even babies with hair this is also the
first time we see some of these alphas
spew blue blood there's a part of them
that is just
unnatural to our world and speaking of
unnatural let's talk about baby zombie
this is the alpha queen and we'll later
see zeus dig out her dead blue baby
fetus
what we don't know is if this baby was
conceived before being infected or if
zeus got it on zombie style and what is
surely to be the grossest new category
on pornhub so the team is able to sneak
their way inside using the coyote with
two extra tag-ons kate scott's daughter
who is looking for gita a quarantine
zone member who has disappeared in vegas
leaving her two kids and then there's
cummings your stereotypical [ __ ] now
when they initially get in there lily
aka the coyote says that the shamblers
weren't smart enough to get out of the
sun so they've kinda dried up
however if there is rain they come back
to life for a few hours
and i thought for sure this meant we'd
see some rain coming later on in the
movie and all these zombies coming back
to life but
that didn't happen we also get our first
sighting of valentine a fictitious
zombie tiger who is associated with
siegfried and roy funny enough it was
carol baskin of tiger king fame who
helped the vfx team with the design
of valentine of course this was before
tiger king became this big pandemic
phenomenon
i am never gonna financially recover
from this the coyote ends up shooting
cummings okay it just sounds wrong to
say shooting cummings
it's an offering of their subservience
around here
zeus is king they end up passing a larry
fong magician poster larry fong being
the cinematographer behind many of zack
snyder's other films such as 300
sucker punch batman v superman and
watchmen he's also somewhat of a
magician
on their way inside the casino which was
actually shot in the former atlantic
club casino in atlantic city which
closed in 2014
martin remarks that las vegas isn't in
america anymore i don't think this has
ever explained why exactly this
is but if i were to hazard i guess it
has something to do with bureaucratic
red tape like it not being part of
america gives the government more leeway
in shooting a nuke there but if you
happen to have a theory let me know in
the comments
martin ends up making a deal with lily
in return for helping him get that sweet
sweet alpha blood which he actually ends
up decapitating the alpha queen
and taking her head not a good move he
agrees to get those in the quarantine
zone released
there's also a fun little set up here
where lily says i've never left anyone i
didn't have to
or who didn't deserve it and will later
end up leaving martin to get maul to
death in a recreation of a siegfried and
roy show
now you may be wondering why these
casinos are so dark even on the playing
floor that's because casinos are
designed to have minimal windows so
people can't see how long they've been
playing they don't even have clocks
casinos want people playing for as long
as possible with no time to reference
how long they've been playing
unfortunately for our gang the
government has decided to launch the
nuke a full day ahead of schedule giving
them just over an hour to complete the
heist
in the fantasy version of the successful
heist that tanaka outlines we see the
vault have these film reels which
zack snyder confirmed as being the
snyder cut of justice league at least
that fantasy became a reality and those
of you with a keen ear may have noticed
that the classical music playing when
they open the vault
is indeed from the opera goddard damaron
and for those familiar with the piece
it's actually a funeral march for
shadowing the death of our main
character as well as countless others
reeling from the death of his queen and
who said zombies don't have emotion
zeus tracks down the team wearing this
kick-ass mask it kinda looks similar to
a deathstroke mask but that might be a
bit of a stretch for some
the main reason he wears it is that it
can deflect bullets his brain being the
only real weak part of his body i also
like that they give him a cape for no
reason whether that's a nod to zack
snyder's connection with superheroes or
ancient greece
we'll need zach to comment below come on
zack gilly lily is smart and beforehand
switch martin's bag that had the head in
it with a money counter machine so it
looks like tanaka won't be getting his
alpha blood
after all or will he more on that in a
bit the last act of the movie sees scott
tracking down his daughter who has gone
after gita at the olympus hotel
damn this gita is causing a lot of
trouble lily sacrifices herself
dropping the queen's head turning it
into a pile of goo as her four remaining
survivors make their escape with zeus
hot on their tail
the copter crashes just as the new kits
vegas and before his death
scott blasts zeus to smithereens as his
life fades when he says his final
goodbye to his daughter
so too does the sun set we do get a
brief glimpse of what appears to be
marianne dead but we don't see what
happened to gita a woman kate spent half
the movie trying to find
that leaves her and vanderhoe as the two
survivors vanderhoe has emerged from the
vault with a [ __ ] ton of cash and i'm
like
how does he not have radiation sickness
well this bite here might have something
to do with it a bite we never see him
contract in the film
first of all let me say if a guy came in
with a duffel bag full of money looking
like this and asked me for a plane i
probably wouldn't give it to him and
second this sets us up perfectly for a
potential sequel with the plane on its
way to mexico city the fifth most
populous city in the world there is a
ton of havoc to be had
you might have also noticed that
vanderhoe has an omega symbol on his
chest the same symbol commonly
associated with the justice league
villain
darkseid and there's a very odd quote by
joseph campbell here that vanderhoe
recites
it is by going down into the abyss that
we recover the treasures of life where
you stumble
there lies your treasure joseph campbell
is known for creating the hero's journey
which outlines how by going through our
own heart of darkness that we stumble
grow and emerge from the other end a
better version of ourselves if you want
to check out a full breakdown of how
home alone follows the hero's journey
and how almost all our stories follow
this structure
check out my video in the description
but what did you think of army of the
dead is this a rotting corpse that
should be left out in the sun or does
this deserve a place alongside
some of the great zombie movies as
always we let the comments decide so get
down there and weigh
in thanks for watching everyone don't
forget to like and subscribe and for
more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter and instagram
at thinkstoryyt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much